no it was okay i wasn't very satisfied
with the
last game i feel like i missed a couple
of
crucial details but um yeah overall
uh reasonable start
and yeah the most important thing on the
first day is not to
to mess up in a major way is that i have
to play catch up now
i can sort of just continue uh continue
playing without
too much pressure yeah so uh how will
you
uh move on from tomorrow
uh i don't know to be to be honest uh i
haven't
haven't thought too too much about it
maybe i'll check out my my pairings when
i get home
okay so um and um how are you feeling
now are you
tired or do you feel you have yeah i'm a
little bit a little bit tired but it's
not too bad
uh after all i've just played played one
day
um but i guess
my my energy levels could have been a
little bit better in the in the last
game but
it's it's fine how was it to play in the
same room as
uh aryan and johan sebastian
uh it was it was fine after a while i
didn't didn't think about
anything and it was pretty close to
playing at home